first carrier.now for Donald Trump is
yet again declaring a fake victory on
saving jobs he's taking credit for
creating or saving a small number of
jobs this time it's at Ford okay and
just like with the carrier deal that we
covered previously the entire narrative
is bogus if not outright deceptive I'll
remind you first about the carrier deal
okay Donald Trump claimed that he got
carrier to keep 1,000 of the 2000 jobs
that they were going to be moving out of
the United States in Indiana he in
exchange for that agreed to give them
millions and millions of dollars in tax
incentives he would stop pushing the
whole idea of the 35% tariff against
companies like them moving jobs overseas
etcetera etcetera this was a disaster it
was a total farce it was not number one
a free market solution that improved
economic conditions in the United States
it was a crony capitalist buddy-buddy
handshake deal done with one specific
company that is not economic policy that
is not something you can replicate
nationally okay we later found out from
Greg Hayes the CEO of the parent company
of carrier that they were going to use
the money they were getting from Trump
to automate their Indianapolis factory
and be able to get rid of even more
employees so the entire thing was a
total gongshow farce and I hope most of
our audience sees through that by now
now we have the four deal okay so let's
leg and dig into that to total house of
cards for Ford announced yesterday
they're going to cancel a 1.6 billion
dollar factory in Mexico
okay well that's interesting what are
they going to do instead instead they're
going to invest up less than half of
that amount of money 700 million in
Detroit's Flat Rock assembly plant
okay good news this is great news the
initial report from Ford CEO mark fields
said that they made this decision in
part because of changing market
conditions with the sale of small cars
declining as well as the pro-business
climate that they expect under President
Donald Trump we actually have a quote
from CEO mark mark fields where he said
we look at all the factors and our view
is we see a more positive US
manufacturing
this environment under president-elect
Trump and the pro-growth policies and
proposals that he's talking about so
this is a vote of confidence for
president-elect Trump and some of the
policies that they may be pursuing okay
got it course the reality is that the
economic conditions that we now see in
the United States have improved
drastically under the guy who's been
president for eight years his name's
Barack Obama but okay they're predicting
even better conditions under Donald
Trump fine they're saying it
Trump immediately tweets about it Trump
takes the Twitter which has become as is
sort of de facto communication tool and
he tweets afford to scrap Mexico plant
invest in Michigan do two Trump policies
quoting an article from Dance Covino on
Fox news.com media reports explode Trump
saves more jobs Trump Trump Trump
corporate media totally bamboozled by
the story first of all we're talking
about 700 jobs okay just like with
carrier a thousand jobs there 700 jobs
here for the 700 workers who get to keep
or or get new jobs for their families
for the small businesses that those
workers and families will be supporting
with the wages that they learn this is
great nobody wants to deny that no one
can deny that but let me remind you that
we've experienced record private-sector
job growth under President Obama month
after month
millions of jobs imagine if corporate
media covered every instance of 700 jobs
created under Obama in this way this is
the way Pat in which Trump has really
manipulated media successfully because
millions and millions of jobs under
President Obama created yeah Bureau of
Labor Statistics and we maybe maybe we
trust the numbers 700 jobs media
explodes there's this great political
cartoon out there of a small donald
trump bragging about the thousand or so
jobs that he saved carrier yeah next to
a giant brock obama saying hey what
about me i saved you know i created 15
million private-sector jobs and what is
it now 80 consecutive months of
something like that yes said if not 80
very very close to it
but then the narrative started falling
apart right the Trump thing grew and
grew Ford CEO Mark fields showed up on
CNBC and said you know what Trump didn't
actually have very much to do with this
he was interviewed on halftime report
and he said the decision not to move
forward with the plant in Mexico was
because of market demand and this is
where it just becomes amazing he said
the bottom line is we're not seeing the
volume in the demand that we expected
for that Mexican plant and therefore
we're looking at our capacity and saying
you know what we can build that in an
existing facility the one that they
already have in Michigan over the last
couple of years we've seen small cars
markedly decline we look at our capacity
we're looking at our forecast do you
guys realize what he's actually saying
here because Ford is underperforming
they don't need as much factory space as
they were going to create in Mexico so
instead they're going to save money and
slightly expand the factory that they
already have in Michigan hey Donald
we're not doing well enough to do the
big plant in Mexico so we'll do a small
expansion in the United States
great Trump victory Trump the job
creator does anybody realize what a joke
this is I I just corporate media
exploded with 700 jobs created this is
because Ford's not doing that well that
they are doing this I don't know how
else to communicate this to our audience
but it is yet another case we had the
carrier deal and then now with the four
deal where it is not as the corporate
media narrative will tell you stunning
this is really because of Ford
struggling that we are seeing this send
your thoughts about this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman today's show is brought to
you by go daddy where you can buy your
own domain name build a website or use
any of Go Daddy's business tools you can
save 30% at try go daddy.com slash David
GoDaddy has actually been the official
host of the David Pakman show web site
for many many many years the 24/7
customer support has been a very good
thing for us I've called them at really
odd times when we we've had website
issues and they are always available
they are the largest
domain registrar and whether you have a
new idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to GoDaddy
they can do it all thirteen million
customers try it and get 30% off at try
go daddy.com slash David